is it better to try to avoid making
money as an artist like
should someone not set out to do their
art
and also try to make money at it right
away
i believe that both can happen and so
i go into it believing this dream will
provide for me
because i have this desire of course
it's going to financially support me as
well
you know it might take time to get to
where you want to be
but i have this whole chapter
i know it keeps dropping my book and
like name dropping my book but i do have
this whole chapter about you know this
idea of
being a starving artist because i think
that those two words you
rarely hear them without each other and
i believe that you don't have to be a
starving artist and i also believe that
there's nothing wrong with desiring
financial success or with you know with
wanting to make money from your art so
to me it's about i believe that i can
create
art that is going to financially support
me and really having that belief
from the beginning most artists don't
make money especially
right up front wouldn't it be easier to
accept that
most artists accepting that belief
equals determining your fate right so
your fate is a hundred percent
dependent upon your belief so if you
believe
that most artists don't make money in
the beginning that 100
will be your fate and what you do when
you accept that belief when you take
that belief on you are now putting
yourself into the most people pool
sure most people don't make a ton of
money in the beginning
do you have to be most people right and
so
can you find an example like i always
love to talk about the example of
gilmore girls this is one of my favorite
shows but
alexis bledel had no acting credits on
her resume before
booking that title lead role
so you know i mean she was modeling
before she had a model in korea there
but
but you know breaking into hollywood as
an actress
and then you know i i don't know what
the going rates were back then but
series regulars now
start at like 25 30 000 an episode
depending on the network right and so
you
so she technically went from zero to
seven you know several thousand dollars
per week per episode and back then they
were doing
22 24 episode seasons so
there's always going to be an exception
to the rule
and i think it's better to focus on the
exception
than to focus on the rule i think it's
better to go into it with
well i could be that exception because
when you when you accept the rule and
you say oh
i'm going to be like most people then
that's exactly what your experience will
be
is there a danger in not thinking that
you're part of that pool
is are you saying like is there a danger
to think of yourself in this smaller
high achievers pool
yeah no i mean what danger i i think
it's like i guess the danger could be
like oh but then you're like putting
yourself in this pool where people make
it and what if you don't
i think that um
there's no danger in believing
that your dreams are possible in a
and this is like the high achiever right
like in a really big way
in in a more committed way than most
people
i i don't think there's any danger in
that and i think that like
the well what if it doesn't happen
i again believe my success is inevitable
so to me there's no specific time frame
that it has to happen and i just know
it's going to happen i don't know when i
don't know how i don't know where
but it's going to happen and i have that
belief throughout
so there's no well if it doesn't happen
by
x that means you're you're in the most
people pool you know i just don't think
that way
do you think other people paying you to
do your art
inherently makes it worse because you
don't have the same level of freedom
to create the art that's in your heart
what if i believed that the work is in
my that the work that is in my heart
is what people will ask for
right so i think it's it's changing the
belief right it's changing the belief
about it like oh
i'm going to do something that's not
really in my heart that i don't really
want to do
because the clients ask me or whatever
right sure that happens and that has
happened on my path you know
like i had day job graphic design jobs
that i did not enjoy but i
but they financially supported me so i
could stay in la and keep doing this so
you know i've had that experience but i
think in the bigger picture
um if i'm doing work that doesn't feel
good
i stop doing it or i don't like there
there was
you know i'll be honest i didn't love
working on cop shows
because from a graphic standpoint it's
really boring you know it's like you're
designing
signs for hospitals and prisons
like all like this is basically the only
graphics i do and the rectangles with
text and that's it you know
it's not a very creative um
you know genre in terms of graphics and
so i did a cop show
i did not enjoy it and then i was like
okay i'm not gonna do this again and
then i would turn down cop shows in the
future right so
so for me it's more about like what if i
just believe that the work i want to do
is what will be asked of me
can you give us an example of that
happening was there an example
where you saw a show that you wanted to
do and you said that's the kind of art i
want to do though that's the color
scheme i like that
how do i make that my reality yeah i
mean
it wasn't that specific in terms of like
color schemes or certain art it was more
just like i would love to do something
that's more creative where maybe every
week the graphics are different
you know where i get to explore more
with like different signage or
different props or you know things that
are integral to the story that are just
inherently more interesting and um you
know shortly after that i did
book a tv show called chasing life which
was the abc family show that i said i
loved which was a great experience and
i got to do really cool fun different
graphics you know
i feel like my portfolio really expanded
from that show because we got to do
um you know so many different things
like we did a marathon once and i got to
do these like marathon banner graphics
but then also
you know the runners tags that they had
to wear and
and then i got to do wardrobe you know
like there was a camp and i got to
design the sweatshirts that the
counselors were
like there was really just variety um
and that was fun for me more so than you
know
the cop graphics kind of stuff where
you're just designing rectangles with
text so
um yeah and then that that became really
fun and i said okay so this is going to
be my new standard
i want to work on a show that feels fun
and creative
um and and you know those are the only
things i would say yes to now
unless it was blade runner then that
would be cool no i i turned down sons of
anarchy oh you did oh wow
no no i i don't care how big the show is
if it's something i know that i
don't think i will enjoy um i won't do
it
my happiness is is now more important so
so the so the lead the colored leathers
on the back of the motorcycle jackets
that just didn't hit you yeah like okay
that'd be cool but my point was that
like
there you know right it wasn't even even
if it's something even if a project is
like big and well known if i don't think
that i will
enjoy doing it then i will still turn it
down sure
sure that makes sense
and i just want to add something there
because some people might be going oh
well you have the luxury of turning it
down because
you're at a certain point in your career
now where you can say no and you know
things are going to come in
but i just want to add on to that is
that when i turn down something that
doesn't feel like a good fit for me
i am making room for something better to
come in
right so as long as you say yes to
things you don't want to do you now
don't even have room for something new
to come in
so you know it's not even necessarily
about
i'm at a certain place in my career
where now i can say no to things to me
it's really about what do i want to make
room for in my life
even if you know the great example is i
talk about
all the time people that stay non-union
you know especially actors you know when
they're afraid to join sag because once
they join sag
they can no longer do non-union work and
that is scary to them because
they only know non-union work and they
feel that non-union
is easier to book than sag work
right and so they like to stay non-union
and i say
when you are staying non-union as long
as you can you are staying where you are
as long as you can
even though it might take a little
longer for the sag stuff to start
flowing in and it might be a little
scarier
that doesn't mean that it won't flow in
and as long as you're choosing the other
thing it'll never flow in
right so it doesn't really matter how
far you are in your career
to be able to turn things down or to you
know to be able to start making room for
what it is you truly
desire it might take some time to bring
it in but you want to at least open
yourself up and make room for the things
that you really want
that's a good example right there yeah i
know a lot of people they pay off they
don't want to pay the dues and they keep
the eligibility status but then they
just keep
keep working yeah good example
you